what you're so scared for older snails
are nice
there can be nice ones who knew a world
of dystopian magic and otherworldly
creatures could be brought to life for
only
30 million dollars while the price tag
might seem a bit hefty
it's surprisingly low considering how
impressive and detailed the monsters in
love and monsters are
so impressive that the vfx team has even
been nominated for an oscar
which monster unintentionally became a
total instagram sensation
did i shoot her did you
what do you think how many creatures
were conceived for 11 monsters
lucky number 13. each of these monsters
were made with very specific
personalities and details from the way
they move to their textures and coloring
extremely important considering they are
the stars of the show and don't even
speak
seeing all these creatures definitely
reminds us of animals we'd recognize in
our world
oh look skye jellies
the team created based on real photos
videos and studies of all these
creatures
from cockroaches to frogs to centipedes
see the resemblances what makes these
creations special is how they look as if
they've been mutated and become entirely
unique
mutated and started eating us looking
closely we can see that each monster has
dirt
scars and other blemishes roughing up
their appearance
these details played a huge role in
bringing them into our reality and
establishing this post-apocalyptic world
now we need to talk about that crab
not only does it bring one of the most
tender moments to life but it looks
unbelievable check out the details on
this creature
we've got six-pack plastic rings here as
well as the crab trap that he managed to
escape and dominate
so what did this crab look like without
all the added effects that brought it to
the screen
well a giant inflatable crab
seriously the base of that monster was a
custom-made powered inflatable creation
that stretched about 30 meters wide and
15 feet tall costing around 700 u.s
it's no surprise the crab accidentally
became an instagram sensation when the
public was able to see this huge
creature flailing in the wind and
honestly looking a little bit ridiculous
that was amazing the crew had their fair
share of laughs over the crab's presence
as well
especially when it was time to deflate
not an
easy task let's just say it involved a
lot of
rolling around and stomping in attempts
to expel all the air
oh yeah when the crab uses its claw
believe it or not
that's almost entirely practical effects
the team had rented a fairly inexpensive
excavator
yes like a construction site excavator
and
souped it right up they took off the
bucket that would normally be at the end
of the arm and attached a claw instead
the whole thing was dressed in blue to
incorporate cgi after the fact
this is probably the first time we've
ever heard of a prop character having a
sort of body double
okay
considering how massive and intricate
some of the creatures were it was really
surprising to learn just how much was
actually results of practical effects
and builds
not just for us though for the creators
too the effects specialists feel that
all the practical effects were a big
contributor to actually grounding the
film
the super cool robot mavis was what the
creators expected to be the most
challenging build
but apart from a couple of small details
the mavis we see on screen was the
practical
puppet built mavis may not have been a
real robot
but it was made out of many pieces a bit
over a hundred parts made with a 3d
printer actually
getting all those parts together now
that was a stressful challenge
only four hours before they shot with
mavis the crew was staring at
all the pieces sitting apart but as we
can see
it all worked out mavis's faceplate and
a bit of the left hand had some cgi work
done
but the biggest change really was hiding
the puppet master who was behind mavis
dressed in a full gray suit
how about that bug monster well it was
an impressive 80
practical piece with digital legs added
to it afterwards
this kind of creature is actually what
inspired the special effects artist
stephen boyle to pursue a career in
effects
the creation was definitely his favorite
of all in this movie
he really appreciated the creativity he
got to put into it
all those creepy crawly way too big for
comfort
sand gobblers acting as kind of
underground tremors were a mix of
puppets ranging from 40 feet to a meter
long and cgi
the queen gobbler that exploded was a
full build for the team
this bulbous and slimy giant frog
creation
well sections of it were built but the
whole of the monster itself was created
digitally
considering how much was practically
created the budget for those was still
smaller than the special effects budget
they definitely matched up in terms of
quality though
the surprisingly friendly boulder snail
about a 15 foot tall and 15 to 20 foot
wide in diameter cgi creation
with every detail covered down to the
slime that coats it
then we get into the stuff of nightmares
as if we weren't there already
yes we're talking about the sirens the
kind of oversized
centipede looking monster for a
relatively blind creature those large
antennae do an
excellent job at helping it navigate
around and totally terrify us
when the film was in post-production it
was realized that the scale of the siren
had to be made even bigger than what
they'd shot for
so vfx was able to scale the creature up
and honestly
it looks pretty flawless
we all know dylan o'brien is an amazing
actor from his performances in the maze
runner movies
but what exactly were his imaginary
co-stars like
well sometimes he was acting terrified
or battling with large blue poles with
some orange on them as we can see here
to mark the size and location of his
acting partner
though luckily not all his co-stars were
imaginary
nor were they human yes we're talking
about hero and dodge
aka the dog named boy o'brien grew
extremely close with his canine co-stars
who did
totally steal the show the animal
coordinator actually said that she'd
never seen such a strong bond between an
actor and these dogs on a set before
it is probably the strongest real life
off-camera bond that we've had with one
of our animals
hero and dodge are very friendly
normally but they put on their best
performances in the scenes where they
appear to be rougher and more aggressive
they were such pros that most of the
shots the teams needed from the dogs
were captured in only one or two takes
o'brien shared in an interview that
working with the dogs and animal
coordinators was definitely one of the
highlights for him
and he hoped to be able to go and visit
them again someday this is a dog
he's brilliant he also noted that they
were excellent cuddle buddies between
takes
we'd probably do the same if we were in
his position maybe all the snuggling
time is the reason he never actually
practiced
drawing we hate to disappoint but all
the beautiful pictures we see later in
the movie
those were actually created by a member
of the props team since in actuality
o'brien is not the best artist early on
in the process he actually did do his
own
drawing which he hoped could be used as
the first example that we see of his
drawing that isn't supposed to look very
good anyway but
even that effort didn't make the cut i
freaking love it that's super sweet
because it's terrible in terms of the
world we're immersed in through the film
the monsters definitely play a major
part but so too does the environment
itself
while the film is meant to take place in
california it was shot in this very
special location in australia chosen
because it already looked so
magical and mystical as it was really
emanating the feeling they wanted the
world of the movie to have
the crew even commented on how magical
the sun looked down under
that alone added to the gorgeous world
we see the team described the area as
looking naturally futuristic
otherworldly and as if all the creatures
they created could
actually be found there there is no
place for mankind on land
the beach area we see here was
completely created in a cove that's
normally covered in grass and park
benches
but it's totally unrecognizable after
the transformation
so how did they do it 600 tons of sand
to restore the whole cove to how it
looked before took about three full
weeks
at least they were working in a
beautiful place with that golden
australia sun though
beautiful it's just not safe right it's
pretty incredible to see how creative
the teams behind the magic are
who knew so many of these complex
creations were created practically
and on such a low budget combined with
dylan o'brien and of course
the real star boy the dog it makes for
an
amazing film were you as blown away by
the mavis puppet as we were